now once you do something a bit weird on
desmos okay here we are
I'm gonna leave it see because I don't
want those markings we had before you
know we put some effort in to turn this
into a pie pie on twos and all that
right this is gonna sound weird but what
is it I'm do that you might be like why
we just put effort into doing it I want
to show you why by doing a bit of an
adjustment here go to where that step
was just delete it and will default back
to just numbers I know the grading is
positive here we know the grading is
some positive number here I want to know
what positive number it is don't go too
fast but start that's not what I wanted
to do sorry start to go toward the
origin like that and what I want you to
notice is in fact I've got a fully it
kind of looks pretty straight right do
you see that in fact it's one of the
things as I looked around I said to some
of you guys your graphs look good goes
through the right spots intercepts are
correct but the shapes a little bit off
this is one of the things I was talking
about it's weird cuz it's curvy mostly
but then in particular spots it's very
straight okay now at this little corner
here from 0.5 0.5 up there
okay I want you to think about the
gradient of this line in fact the
section I'm showing entirely straight
isn't it there's a little cabin on that
what's the gradient here it's it's
pretty bang onto one right look here you
go
run is 0.2 and then rise also 0.8 in
fact the closer you go go ahead just go
bananas and zoom in and zoom in and zoom
in right so what is the equation of the
line that's straight goes the origin it
has a gradient of one Michael's X right
on this part here we can put the
equations on y equals x if you've zoomed
in as far as I have you cannot
distinguish the two graphs right they
are bang on okay so what can we
determine here let's just come back up
what have we got on our little sort of
list here okay
we've determined yet it's interesting
right will you determine that the
derivative should be periodic
we know these particular spots when the
derivative should be zero we also these
particular spots when the dually should
be positive or negative
and lastly add a spotlight x equals zero
this is not the only one by the way I
want you to tell me another one in a
second at a spot like that
the derivative in fact is equal to what
did we just work out what number it was
one right again tell me another spot
where the derivative would be one let me
just put this back in tell me another
spot
exactly the spot we should look at list
the clues it's periodic right see if it
was it was a great inner one here it
should be a radiative one two pi radians
later and another two pi and so on okay
draw a new set of axes it's gonna go
from 1 to 2 pi lose together
great luck on your end chance
now as you're putting together that set
of axes this is what I'd like you to
make it look like and I'm going to
explain to you I'm trying to so firstly
we know this is a graphic yacht so
whatever I'm gonna get I want to repeat
over and over again okay I also know
there are some crucial spots that worked
out there are stationary points on my
cosine X which is gonna be my derivative
of sine X it's going to be zero
that you helped me identify so I'm going
to up mark them in a little more heavily
yes I on two right there and there's
three PI ng so faster good what's this
green shading about this is it goes up
and down
what's this reflect how do we get this
information going down it was dropping
so we knew as a decreasing function that
means the grading will be negative
positive and then lastly velocity
inflation is at x equals zero that's at
x equals zero we actually went and
investigated what the gradient became it
was exactly one so this we also noticed
the old player we observed the same
gradient which didn't surprise us is
periodic one you can see it on your
breath wait he read x equals PI on the
sine graph the grading is not 1 it's not
zero what is it give me negative it's
the opposite isn't it because all of the
trigonometric a this wonderful studio so
there it is down there now by now
hopefully you are not just suspicious
like I only know a single does this that
goes through those spots its period I'd
like you described
what is your okay let's go ahead can we
draw it in please okay we're gonna get
this shape here is equal to the limit as
H approaches zero of Y and in this weird
function notation here f of X plus h
minus f of X on H you have to do this
with sine X which is kind of requires a
bit of the stuff from the extension
course and number two roughly takes
about three times longer but this that's
part of why we're doing this this is not
a proof but it is still a visual
intuition which we backed up with some
data of sine x equals what it's it's cos
that's the function that would pay love
wait okay it takes all the boxes it does
exactly what we need it to do and like I
said what I'm happy to show you the
formal rigorous proof for this but it's
a bit longer too